Let's go next to our caller from the 3:53
area code who's calling today from 3:53.
What's going on, Dave?
Hey, who's this?
Can you hear me?
My name's Bird.
Hey, Bird, what's up?
Oh, not much.
I enjoyed that last bit.
Yeah, sort of.
All right.
My question would be, why does the press corps,
when they're listening to Donald Trump and
he's just blabbing on or when he personally
attacks them?
Yeah.
Why don't they grow the balls and actually
snap back at him?
Why are they just sitting there hanging their
heads and letting him ramble?
Yeah, I know what you mean.
I would love.
I mean, so.
So here's the thing.
There's a balance.
First of all, even if you have a president
who has thrown all guidelines of decorum into
the trash, the press corps is still relatively
collegial.
And they have a code of conduct and they are
journalists and they sort of abide by it.
They don't throw their code of conduct out
the window just because Trump does.
What I would like to see is when shit like
to.
A couple of days ago, Trump said, I'm withholding
money from the W.H.O..
Five minutes later, someone said, is that
a good idea?
And he said, I never said I was withholding
money from the W.H.O..
I would like to see everybody in the room,
read the quote back to him and confront him
with it.
But the reality is, if you call great things.
If you call on ones like if you call Trump
out on a lie, he'll tell three more lies and
it branches virally.
So I don't really know that you get anywhere.
I feel like it's it's kind of it's almost
a lost cause.
It may seem that way, I guess.
Know.
I don't understand it myself.
I'm not I'm not a journalist.
I don't think I could personally sit there
and listen and talk without saying something,
you know.
And maybe they should.
Maybe they should.
They should push harder.
Maybe draw them out.
The real Donald Trump, you know, because this
this Bush persona puts on now, you know, act
like hereeven act present and presidential
now, you know, so.
But I think if they pushed him a little harder,
you know, he you know, he bites snapped.
Anyway, I agree with you.
I mean, was on meltdown when Trump does get
pushed a little more or he gets asked what
he considers a nasty question.
He does snap.
He starts pointing at reporters and saying,
you're a third rate journalist.
You should be ashamed of yourself.
You're never going to succeed.
That's the realest trump that we ever see
any very quickly snaps.
And that's what he's known for doing in private
with his own employees and people who work
for him.
Like I believe that's the closest to the real
Trump we ever see.
And I love that the fact that he calls every
honest question like.
You know, it's a legitimate question.
How can you call it, Nancy, especially when
they're quoting him.
Yeah.
No, no, no.
So here's the code windbags.
Do you know if Trump says that's a beautiful
question?
It's a softball, usually from 0 a.m..
Right.
If Trump says the question is sort of nasty
or that the journalists should be ashamed
of themselves, that's the thread you want
to be pulling on because you're actually getting
at something Trump doesn't want to talk about.
In their praise is so blatant.
Yeah.
I mean, everybody else in the room turns to
look at it because there's an ego.
No, Mr. President.
You're so strong.
You're so big and strong.
That's the way it goes.
Yeah.
When you see, I know it's absolutely kills
me.
Who the hell is asking that?
It's usually because it's.
Oh.
And asking some brown nosing question.
Well, he loves parades.
He does, certainly does, Bird.
Thank you for the call.
Very much.
Appreciate it.